vrai partage avec vous une conviction
formidable c'est que nous sommes bien
née notre génération mais vraiment au
sens large et bien à la chance de vivre
un temps exceptionnel non pas comme une
génération sur trois le temps que nous
vivons aujourd'hui c'est un temps tels
que trente générations n'ont pas connu
trente générations c'est à peu près ya
500 ans c'était quoi ya 500 ans
qu'est ce qui fonde la modernité c'est
la renaissance et on vit aujourd'hui une
période qui est de la kabylie en plus
intéressant encore que la renaissance
c'était pour la renaissance était quatre
piliers comme des quatre piliers d'une
table et on a au moins trois de ces
plier encore plus fortement plus
fortement nuque les premiers piliers de
la renaissance était une croissance
démographique
sayah que les historiens ou vit
aujourd'hui une révolution démographique
sans précédent sous napoléon 1er en 1804
exactement il y avait qu un milliard de
terriens
on est sept milliards de terriens depuis
octobre 2014
en 2025 c'est apporter du camp même où
sera 8 milliards
la population mondiale va culminer aux
alentours de 2050
entre 9 milliards 1 et 9 milliards fois
ce qui veut dire qu'en 32 ans
vous allez avoir nous allons avoir deux
milliards de terriens en plus soit deux
fois la population mondiale aps d'époque
napoléon 1er
donc tous ceux qui disent à croissance
est finie circulez ya plus rien à voir
en tant qu'économiste l'historien j'ai
quelques doutes
alors sans doute faut-il une autre forme
de croissance et dans les pays qui ont
la chance d'être à peu près comme le
nôtre il voulait que je suis convaincu
que les modes de consommation ont changé
on a dans la plupart des landes des
langues deux auxiliaires être et avoir
tout la consommation depuis les temps
les plus et mémoriaux sont basés sur la
voir que toujours plus ne pas tenir de
toujours mieux on va et vous le sentez
bien d'ailleurs depuis quelques années
quelque 2 ou 3 ans peut-être bien
d'ailleurs peut-être ce lundi par
certains côtés on parle de plus en plus
d'une consommation qui est basée sur
l'être en tk nous vivons ce temps
incroyable avec un premier poster une
poussée démographique deuxième booster
deuxième pilier de la renaissance
c'est énormément de découvertes
techniques nous avait tous au fond de
votre rétine les formidable invention
léonard de vinci
mais vous savez peut-être même mieux que
moi tourments que depuis quinze ans on a
plus découvert que durant nous l'avons
second monster la renaissance troisième
booster la renaissance était de
nouvelles routes au double cap de bonne
espérance le sud de l'afrique ce qui
permet de mettre fin au commerce
équitable puisque on va chercher des
pistes et parfois directement par vaux
atlantique puis 14 192 bien sûr la
découverte de l'amérique
mais aujourd'hui pendant 15 ans nous
avons déjà de nouvelles routes maritimes
les passages du nord nord-ouest nord-est
alors je m'en réjouis pas parce que
c'est en partie la conséquence du
réchauffement climatique pose bien des
problèmes mais ça ouvre des opportunités
ponctuellement qui paraîtra peut-être de
lutter contre l'excès de co2 vous voyez
ces trois premiers booster var défense
où les amants le seul élément qui peut
guider par rapport à mai
les carnets sont c'était sous tendu par
une philosophie résolument optimiste
porter des lans qui faisait qu'on nous
ait osé c'est l humaniste et aujourd'hui
on est plutôt c'est le seul élément qui
me nommant et peut être particulièrement
au sein d'union européenne et peut-être
perros à l'union européenne
au niveau de la france avons-nous
confiance on attend pour réussir mais on
n'ose pas quand on a peur on est dans
l'enfermement dans le protectionnisme
diront certains quand on a confiance
dans l'avenir vous êtes ouvert que je
voudrais très rapidement vous montrer
c'est que c'est une nouvelle partie qui
commence et nous sommes particulièrement
bien positionné je voudrais d'abord vous
montrer la vraie carte de france
c'est vrai car bleu foncé poisse et pas
uniquement un hexagone avec une ou deux
bouteilles qui est en bas à droite c'est
vous avez là c'est tous les territoires
de la nation française partout de par le
monde
alors les points cardinaux n'ont pas été
respectées parce que voilà la carte
officielle du grenelle de la mer c'était
l'époque de bienvenue chez les ch'tis
donc si on avait mis la métropôle au
nord on aurait dit que c'était déjà
préfiguration de jupiter j'en sais rien
mais en tous les cas ce qui est certain
c'est que si vous prenez la polynésie
118 rivaux il fait ça s'étend selon
europe physique énorme on voit que c'est
quoi cette carte de france c'est tous
les territoires nation française avec
une caractéristique c'est la mère qui
est au coeur de l'ensemble de la nation
française il faut joie autrement
la chance de la france ces luttes rohmer
la chance de l'union européenne c'est la
france et son micro mère pourquoi est ce
que je vous dis ça je voudrais je suis
historien
pour moi la plus grandes dates de
l'histoire de france et peut-être hormis
un ou deux vous étiez tous présents
c'est pas 15 centaines si c'est
important de mettre la pâtée aux suisses
mais en terme géopolitique laissé tomber
est important pour les fans espagnols
c'est 1994 le mondial de foot ou sous
les 98 en 1994 c'est un nouveau droit de
la mer en laissez moi expliquer tous
pays bordier d'un océan à une zone
d'exclusivité économique de 200 milles
marins le mille marin c'est 1852 met
donc 200 x 1852 m égale 372 km donc à
partir de chaque île française de chaque
faute française vous pouvez en gros
faire un périmètre pour calculer le
domaine maritime à partir d'un rayon de
370 kilomètres à peine de la france
depuis 1994 le deuxième domaine maritime
mondial
j'ai regardé mes mots à l'apogée de la
foule vienne m au fil de votre histoire
jamais le pays n'a été aussi grand film
mais depuis 1984 bien sûr ça fait
beaucoup d'autres domaines comme la nia
l'homme politique agaçait kodo kodo
après n'y aura pas d'ici là dessus mais
vous avez tout dans l'univers
d'abord la mer c'est seul but faire
enquête dimension il ya la surface et la
tranche dont ya les terres il
hergé qui représente 72 % de la surface
de la planète et on sait depuis quelques
mois que la diversité du sous-sol
terrestre mara est différente de la
biodiversité du sous-sol terrestre il
fasse rêver pour montrer que
l'impossible venir possible sur quelque
chose qui vous tient à coeur
souvent pour les plus âgés d'entre nous
voulaient croire alors de la fraude
fiscale sarret vous pas vous dire là
c'est vraiment aussi ça sera peut-être
possible par les terres rares mais
terreur sa porte très mal son nom la
terre comme la faire ces 17 métaux
stratégiques que vous avez plein sur
vous les high palmer iphone y compris
les pales d'éoliennes la chine exporte
aujourd'hui 96 % des terres rares
mondiale et président chinois he
pingping et patou blaise dernière pluie
a décidé depuis trois ans de baisser
progressivement ses exportations de
terrain depuis on va les chercher
partout on a découvert ou là l'archipel
de la société disons tahiti pour faire
toujours des réserves terreur qui
représentent aujourd'hui 18 % des ter a
reconnu notre pays la france l'union
européenne grâce à la france dispose
d'une réserve incroyable c'est rare et
en termes technologiques vous avez que
deux pays qui disposent de l'essentiel
de la technologie et des entreprises
pour aller chercher à 3 km et livre
profondeur cette terreur sans palmes
samba on est bien d'accord c'est les
états unis et la france voulaient encore
un autre élément de poids est confiant
on a tout essayé
dans ce pays dans la lutte contre le
chômage sauf qu'une chose
une politique maritime alors je voudrais
très rapidement dire ce que c'est une
petite barre haïti parce que de vous
dire qu'il s'est trompé de tedx sepa
belfort le red bull en bretagne c'est
pas une politique maïs il s'est passé
quelque chose qui vise à développer la
croissance bleue uniquement pour le
leader un nom c'est faire rentrer la mer
à l'intérieur du territoire et vous dire
des choses absolument serait sur
lesquels dans travaillée retravaillée
avec mes étudiants
sachez que tout passe par des conteneurs
aujourd'hui en dehors du pétrole et du
gaz et bien aujourd'hui deux conteneurs
sur 3 me rends tous qui sortent de
france passe par anvers hambourg et
rotterdam j'ai pire la région paca un
conteneur sur deux qui rend ton fils en
la région paca passe par anvers hambourg
et rotterdam
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire que nos
pays notre pays ne peut pas être
compétitif
quelle est l'entreprise qui n'a pas
besoin d'acheter pour produire et de
vendre mes étudiants d'en montrer
preuves à l'appui que la région
française la plus relié aux maritimes
s'appelle l'alsace-lorraine plein vous
dès qu'elle nomme cette vérité plus vous
vous décalez jeu l'impossible est
impossible voyez ça dépend quand vous
regardez les choses vous décalez
l'alsace lorraine - votre entreprise
sera compétitive heureusement qu'elle
préfère qu'on vous dit pas tout ça parce
que il ya de quoi vous révolter quand
vous étiez d'entreprise est visé au
dessus de la loire on vous parle
beaucoup de la production de proximité
et qu'est ce que ça veut dire prendre
leur à proximité
shanghai est plus près d'anvers en terme
de pouvoir même de pollution parfois
entre anvers premier port français et la
ville de rennes un frigo était qu un peu
parce que ces gros ça ça coûte pas cher
lupu transport du frigo entre shanghai
et anvers ou 300 fois moins cher sur le
coup de se transformer frigo contre
anvers et affiche de rennes est une
ville au nord de la france mais
indépendamment de la compétitivité si
vous voulez retrait la compétitivité il
faut pour deux grands ports c'est comme
ça qu'on les appelle en plus le havre et
marseille marche mais un conteneur cas
rivaux à vue n'a l'air mal à vous le
retirez du bateau pour mettre sur un
train qui va faire des bêtises
d'après le retirer une frappe fort mais
sur une barge et le conteneur qui
arrivera par en veille et bien longtemps
qu'il est là et en plus ça coûte moins
cher vous êtes posé la question en terme
d'accidentologie très difficile à
calculer cette pose la question en
termes de pollution est une pollution
incroyable aujourd'hui notre pays ou
deux grands ports sont des culs de sac
pourquoi parce qu'il faudrait une ligne
tgv paris normandie pour avoir plus de
ces unions ferroviaire pourquoi parce
qu'il faudrait également pousser ainsi
on fait revenir au niveau de lyon et
marseille pour désenclaver le problème
tant que la mer n'est pas à l'intérieur
du territoire
nous payons gaspillons du co2 parce
qu'il nous ment ici ou là des autoroutes
parce que nous n'avons pas suffisamment
de voies ferroviaires et parce qu'à
l'époque de louis xiv n'aimait plus de
voies navigables en france aujourd'hui
donc on va qu'une politique maritime
c'est celle qui nous remettrait en place
sur le plan de la compétitivité
y a pas que le coût des matières
premières y a pas que le coût du travail
dans le présent un public est allé en
chine j'ai quand même repart et que la
france un déficit de 20 milliards de
dollars par an avec la chine quand
l'allemagne ce à des prix un tout la
manoeuvre à s'élever à 30 milliards
d'excédents vous voyez le manque de
fluides
la nécessité d'avoir une politique de
désenclavement politique d'aménagement
du territoire c'est possible je voudrais
vous dire c'est que oui à un
porte-conteneurs 1 par compteur ces huit
mille camions pour le décharger ses 97
km de peillon nous avoue ou pour
respecter des délais de la circulation
ça ferait 234 vous voyez que ce qui
coûte cher ce qui pollue c'est pas même
s'il paraît infiniment moins connu c'est
le reste c'est de devoir importer de
très loin d'aider et prodigue qu'il faut
traverser faire traverser à six camions
l'ensemble du territoire
je voudrais vous dire que c'est que nous
sommes dans un nouveau temps dans une
nouvelle période de l'histoire de
nouveau tant ses seules villes l'océan
mondial
il ya deux moteurs dans l'histoire et
pas le temps développer la mer la
démographie est ce qui caractérise le
temps dans lequel nous rentrons c'est
que la mer la démographie se mettent en
interférence en tenue 25 75 % de la
population mondiale va se trouver
concentrer sur une bande littorale de 75
km de là sauf qu'on sera mis à passer au
pic démographique en 2050 près
stabilisés sur cette même bande
littorale de 75 km de là
retenez bien ce chiffre deux fois par
les 75 64 jusqu'à 80% la population les
327 experts du grenelle de la mer ont
montré que la mer contient la quasi
totalité des solutions pour un avenir
myope durable il faut qualifier de
désirable du paletot tout évoquée mais
vous avez mais hydroliennes et les
énergies marines sur le plan de la santé
mais un espoir est né quand je
commençais à travailler sur la mer il ya
vingt ans peut-être même un peu plus
maintenant
on croyait connaître 15 à 20% de la
faune et de la flore sous marine
aujourd'hui avec le développement la
métagénomique qui consiste à faire le le
séquençage n'ont pas de gêne isolé du
croisé on ne connaît pas plus de 3
et en plus d'être magnifique mais on est
tous des poissons desséché on sait que
la vie elle émane du milieu marin j'ai
pour ça que dans le domaine de la mer
qu'on va trouver la santé donc attention
nous n'aurons pas d'esclandre chance on
va pouvoir passer grâce à la mer mais
n'imposons pas la mer le traitement
qu'on lui a fait subir
et puis je terminerais parce que le
temps tourne vite nous rentrons dans un
nouveau ton histoire
il suppose une nouvelle manière de voir
et qui provoque une nouvelle
géopolitique
aujourd'hui je voudrais vous compterez à
comment les chinois pensent cet étonnant
montrer comment les chinois voient le
monde alors qu'ils se mettent au milieu
ça chacun le fait si vous achetez à
venir un planisphère vous voyez états
unis au milieu j'ai demandé le
remboursement annoncé qu'ils sont
trompés de sens on voit que la chine
aujourd'hui se lance vers une issue
elle se veut être la grande puissance de
l'hémisphère sud desmond ces cartes qui
sont en français mais qui émane des cas
nous avons pu intercepter il ya quelques
années parce qu'il faut se mettre dans
la pensée chinoise qui on veut voir ce
qui se passe intéressez-vous l'indonésie
intéressez-vous mecs libre en parle pas
beaucoup aujourd'hui
il secondera est obscène qu'est ce que
ferait la chine aujourd'hui elle lance
un projet dont on ne parle pas dont on
parle pas dans nos écoles de commerce et
qui va modifier toute la donne
wild one bale les nouvelles routes de la
soie c'est petit c'est à dire que le
président chinois l'audi à l'horizon
2030 2035 la chine sera l'épicentre des
flux logistiques
il dominera la planète comme jamais les
américains auront pu y parvenir par le
biais militaire ils veulent jouer
gagnant gagnant ne faisons pas la
politique de l'autruche il ya plein
d'opportunités plein de portes
une chine qui développe le brésil je
passe très vite et à partir de ce moment
là des routes de la soie qui vise aussi
écarté l'un l'autre géant asiatique qui
aura une population supérieure à celle
de la chine en 2030 pourquoi la la chine
regarde vers le sud
tout simplement parce que ça fait trop
connu dans le marigot l'hémisphère nord
vous en avez trois ans ferme or les
européens
il en reste et on continue à gré à tenir
malgré les coups de rabot des deux côtés
du russe et de l'américain les nord
américains et les russes c'est très
difficile on compte trois enfants il
serait très difficile d'avoir trois
enfants c'est souvent de contrat toute
l'actualité pas forcément la cote et
télévisée mais les jeunes lisent les
journaux regardait le feuilleton c'est
mieux que netflix ou aujourd'hui vous
allez découvrir que tous les jours il se
passe des choses
aujourd'hui vous voyez que l'union
européenne est en train d'épier des deux
côtés parce que c'est à ceux qui seront
deux contre un et la russie ni molesté
quasiment cette europe il n'y aura pas
d'europe du temps tu rends pas de rock
mick l'union européenne c'est le plus
grand domaine maritime au monde
c'est le plus grand linéaire de pouce
c'est le plus grand nombre de navires et
nous n'avons pas de politique maritime
au niveau européen pas plus que nous
n'avons de politique maritime en france
voire même de politique de l'outre-mer
voudrais terminer en disant que cette
nouvelle zone
je conclurai en vous disant on rentre
dans un nouveau dans l'histoire vous
l'avez compris pour bien montrer les
choses on passe pas d'une période à une
autre comme le 14 juillet 1789 à 12h12
sam et 30 ans
ça fait 25 ans qu'on a eus stationnement
dans cinq ans la part qui va commencer
on est dans ce temps incroyable où la
part qui n'a pas encore commencé on
vient de distribuer vos cartes vous
découvrez vos cartes
certaines vous plaît vous plaise ou
moins la france lui à descartes encore
fabuleuse c'est le moment où vous faites
votre jeu on n'a jamais vu un joueur de
cartes l'aisne la partie sud kivu et la
bataille des poutres et donc d'enfants
vos confrères gagner sans avoir répondu
c'est le moment de faire votre jeu vaut
personnellement qu'est ce que c'est que
la géopolitique sa rapport à l'espace et
au temps
quel est votre gestion du temps prenez
vous le temps de penser demain 1er vous
le temps de vous battre et ce que
j'entendais avec l'avenir
qu'est ce que vous voulez faire demain
qui n'existe pas encore aujourd'hui tout
est ouvert
tô t possible sortait du cadre ouvrez
tous et votre gestion de l'espace
belfort la france lueur comment ça se
passe j'ai ouvert une confidence je suis
mise au tempérament et optimiste
par le raisonnement est optimiste par
mes étudiants tous se rencontrent le
marbre fait c'est le moment de faire vos
dieux à titre personnel par rapport à
votre vie par rapport à votre métier
c'est le moment de faire son jeu au
niveau entreprenariale c'est pas parce
que votre entreprise avec 10 de plus
donc depuis 250 ans fera dans deux ans
comment gérer cet espace comment gérer
ce temps et bien sûr c'est vrai au
niveau des états et la france est une
puissance moyenne intermédiaire peu
formidablement joué dans cette logique
de bloc on a des partenariats incroyable
par rapport à l'afrique 650 millions
d'africains n'ont pas accès à
l'électricité
et nous sommes confrontés à un défi qui
ne sera pas celui de l'eau il sera le
défi du sable imaginez niche par niche
des produits de substitution aux sables
à commencer par la construction de sable
du désert est impropre pour construire
la tête retournée boulet à travers les
siècles
en un mot je termine mes dires du patron
temps certainement sans fond du cadre
sortait du cadre penser différemment
ne vous mettez pas de barrière nous
sommes confrontés un temps incroyable
c'est pas un temps de crise tous ceux
qui parlent de crise doivent repasser
leurs femmes au fort changer de lunettes
tous nos systèmes m'entourent sont
périmés il faut ouvrir
il est possible que la mentalité chinois
soit plus adapté agirait le complexe
parce que eux ils font de la physique
quantique ils font des mathématiques
quantique et à travers leur vision du
ying ayant quitté penser à chez nous la
thèse et l'antithèse tour e thèse
antithèse de ligne ayant tu sais pas
contradictoire c'est ce j'irai sur un
autre plan apprenez à voir différemment
à gérer l'espace différemment et faites
vous plaisir
[Applaudissements]